hi there is too much talent in this one
room you are all so incredible
congratulations
um we need to talk about that opening
performance of Greece is the word the
dancing the singing the costumes how
much preparation went to that number
gosh it took us months to to finally be
able to to record that number we was one
of the first dances that we learned
um and and there was so much preparation
I also feel like within the creative
team they probably spent a really long
time trying to perfect it and figure out
what exactly that number was going to be
and we were waiting too we were waiting
for there's so many logistical things
that you have to wait for like a
location and then weather they wanted to
shoot when it was going to be nicer
which was ironic because of range the
whole time so then we had to we had to
wait a lot that night when we were
shooting Greece is the word so we had
less time to shoot things too because of
the rain and it was um it was very cold
we were shooting things at 4am uh
there's a lot that goes into things that
I feel like you don't really know behind
the scenes we've got this giant fan this
wind machine it's it's blowing dust into
the dancer's eyeballs but they are
killing it yeah you'd never know yeah
and even just like moments of like the
costumes the amount of times that we
tested Nancy has this fabric that she
lets go of and it it blows in the wind
we tried so many different ways and to
make sure that it was exactly what it
needed to be and you know
perfectly yeah so it's one thing to to
shoot it and to have all these elements
and to be preparing for it for months
but then when you fat when you saw the
final product what was your reaction
Goosebumps yeah
wow we actually got the chance to watch
that like when we were filming episode
eight oh good yeah we got to view it a
little early I think it was just like a
gift to us to be like this is what your
hard work looks like so far so keep
going at it keep going yeah and um it
was just amazing we understood I think I
think it was even more of an idea of
like what we're doing here is a big deal
yeah well speaking of this series being
a huge deal reu posted this great video
of the show
um being up on uh the Billboards in
Times Square was that moment like for
you seeing that I wish we were there in
person I know we got to enjoy it in
person I was from a text message
actually we hear about it and we like or
we can't wait we are going to New York
soon so hopefully we'll be able to see
it and get that excited moment but I
mean it's unreal this has been dreams I
think for all of us since we were little
and
finally here yes what's so cool about
this show is Rise of the Pink Ladies is
a grease for a whole new generation how
familiar were you with the original
movie or and how much did you have to
like do a serious Deep dive into that
world it's pretty familiar I mean you
can't really exist on Planet Earth and
not know about true I know about Greece
um I think I think I was introduced to
it a little bit younger than I probably
should have been but because of that
it's always been and um in my blood and
my body you walk around you hear all the
music all the time and then when we got
the project and we we very much studied
the films front to back over and over
and over again because there's this very
what we call Grease energy and tone to
the grease films that we wanted to
replicate because it's it's a little
heightened but it's also grounded in the
truth of just being this very colorful
world of the 50s
um and yeah I think I think we set out
to accomplish that absolutely oh you
definitely did the music as you were
saying is Iconic I think one of my
favorite performances from the original
film is Beauty School Dropout I just
love how weird it is in the dream
sequence if you had to go back in time
and insert yourself into a song from the
original film what performance do you
wish you were a part of
um I'm gonna say greased lightning for
myself yeah because I kind of got to do
that with our song new cool
um obviously the original you can't
touch it it's like it's it's just
masterful so yeah certainly grease
lighting for me I think I would love to
go back to Hand Jive uh because yeah I'm
a social swing dancer and so I just do
this for fun all the time I like Wendy
hop that's just kind of what I do and it
was really exciting to work on this
series too because Jamal Sims our
choreographer he knew this about me and
he was like we're gonna try to find a
moment to Showcase that so if you want
to choreograph a quick little thing
where we'll just put it in there like so
cool what what but so it'll be part of a
a dance number where you have a partner
and you could do lists and like really
fun stuff I would oh
to be in that gym where the cake is
melting apparently right yeah
that was my favorite I love a good
slumber party as the good girl I invite
all my girlfriends over all the time
um but I also think I I always wanted to
go to that Carnival yeah that was fun
yeah it would be mine just because being
a little Carnival and everybody dance
and having fun
yeah and you guys obviously know how to
do big numbers very very well
um has anybody from the original cast
reached out to you and shown their
support
I I actually heard from uh DD Con my
friend gifted me with the Cameo from her
right when we were starting to film and
and she's very excited about the project
and
um had a lot of advice to give and
shared some stories from her on set and
I think it was a really nice gesture and
a way of being like all right take it
over it's it's yours and I also got a
little video from the actor who plays uh
Duty in the original film
um and and he was so supportive and
wonderful and just like the nicest
person
um so from what we've heard like the the
cast the original cast has been in the
movie has been really supportive and
like really wonderful everybody's got
videos where's my video John yeah
we need to make this happen
um is it true that there's over 30
original songs in this series yes true
yes
you know with having to do such a deep
dive in the original film and and
knowing that music so well how much fun
was it creating new music but also
keeping the spirit of of that time
period in the original movie that was
all handled by our incredible
songwriting team led by Justin trantor
and even Brittany Campbell and um Chloe
Papas like you were saying really helped
with the vocal production of the show
and um in terms of trying to gear it
towards lightning what do we want to do
modern 50 that was all them their
creative product they nailed it on the
head and then our job was just to come
and perform it um I know that makes it
sound easy it wasn't but also the coach
does through different Renditions of
what they wanted it to be you know
certain songs wanted to have this kind
of a Vibe this kind of an edge this kind
of you know so that was all a
collaboration and it wasn't just singing
it was hey we actually want you to sound
a little bit more like this can we work
on this part of your voice you know and
you stretched out yeah like I was oh man
I was working on that every day I'm like
I don't know if I'm doing it justice
yeah
okay and I got the wrap but aside from
the cold because I know you shot in bcra
what was your favorite thing about
shooting in Canada
the people the people are me I love our
cats yeah yes and their crew and the
dance Community is incredible this
community is insane out there they're so
good there's incredible dancers out in
Vancouver
okay well thank you so much
congratulations you guys like this is
amazing